[Applaudissements]
les enfants bon ouais on se croit pas
trop je descends vite chez mes deux
petits jeunes tu es bien pressé nounours
nous allons jouer ensemble ce qu'on va
s'amuser
je peux à lui patron wind nours mais ne
vous disputez pas jusqu'aux dont le seul
tort
au
moustoir les enfants'' a mal à un jeu
wii on joue à quoi elle a peut-être au
nom si nous faisions une petite partie
bridge qu'est ce que serait un jeu de
cartes pour gens disent pas non
plus car tu avais enfin
à quoi on joue à l'eau j'ai une bonne
idée en fait oui
au japon vol c'est un buso sans jamais
tu vas voilà jeudi des noms d'animaux et
vous devez lever le doigt ou la pac
lorsque c'est un animal ou quelque chose
qui peut voler
et c'est hyper hyper un gage ou y
allons-y je sens que je vais calme une
vision naïve et ivan avions volent
chaises volent nos noces s'était trompé
à gabon si on veut canaries
non je n'ai pas levé ma patte oui mais
non c'est toi nicolas c'est pas vrai pas
normal c'est pas moi c'est pas beau
cliché ne est allé battre non et puis
moi je ne joue plus avec vous non eh
bien tu vas payer dégage non je ne peux
rien du tout car j'ai gagné moi
voilà patron j'avais
excusez moi les enfants mon patron me
réclame
si c'est pas malheureux moi qui avais
gagné
allons je vous accompagne au lit non
alors pour les achats nuit nounours bah
nuit
de toute façon je n'ai rien compris à ce
jeu
on aurait mieux fait de jouer au paris
[Musique]
dans nuit enfants
à
te voilà gros traînards vous n'êtes pas
gentilles pas trop je suis à peine
descendue chez nicolas et pimprenelle
que vous m'a plu avec votre pipeau il
est tard nounours les petits enfants
doivent aller se coucher et il faut que
tu montrent le bon exemple
bon jusque vous le dites voulons en
route bourse en dormez vous bien
sagement les enfants
le feuilleton bourg
[Musique]
oh
à
bon
non